good morning believe nation today's
message is push through over to you Mike
Rasheed there's different types of
people in this world and one thing that
we'll all want to deal with is like
difficulties in our tasks trying to
become successful as good as things get
you have the same amount of bad that's
going to try to impede your progress
whether it be people whether it be the
IRS whether it be whatever something
will rear its ugly head and try to block
you now a lot of people can't handle
that [ __ ] when you have a vision and
something or someone throws a curve ball
it hurts this thing's right it's like
your baby and now I can't put my baby
out there like I want to do it so it
really throws people off that you can
negatively maybe the president might
want to stop they might want to just go
back to their 9:00 to 5:00 that's fine
is not for everybody to push through but
for those who camp was to like he said
the difference between those who really
succeed no don't are the ones who when
they're faced with whatever these
difficulties are they like that I'm
gonna keep pushing through I'm gonna
keep pushing through because there's
some corny and cliche but it's always
sunshine after the rain you gonna say
rain don't last that long
you got to know that be aware that
that's when you can take what you do
with everything in life but in business
you cannot stop because things I don't
want to write at the time because it's
gonna happen
I've dealt with it I'm sure I doing it
again at some point starting the
business is gonna be one of the hardest
things that you ever do in your life
period
it just is if you think starting a
business is gonna be easy you are so
disillusioned and you're setting
yourself up for failure you may have a
easy idea you may think it's so simple
but the execution of it building up
momentum getting customers getting this
thing out there adding value is hard
it's gonna be one of the hardest thing
if not the hardest thing that you ever
do in your life and it's totally worth
it and it's totally rewarding
but I want to set up your expectations
because as fun as entrepreneurship is
and how great it is to be your own boss
to set your own hours and do something
meaningful and have an impact and make
way more money like as awesome as that
is it's also a grind and a battle and
and constantly daily fighting you know
self-worth when your thing your idea
doesn't take off and doesn't work
immediately it's hard when I was in the
venture capital business we'd often
challenge the people coming to raise
capital to give us three scenarios your
realistic case scenario your worst case
scenario and your best case scenario if
we give you a million dollars for your
company give us a three scenarios best
realistic worst-case scenario how does
that money come back to us what does
that look like in the growth of your
business we would always only look at
the worst case scenario and then imagine
it's gonna be worse than that so like if
we're not making money off of the worst
case scenario then forget about it
and if we're barely making money off the
worst case scenario then probably forget
about it too because it's likely gonna
be way worse than the worst case
scenario and entrepreneurs are
optimistic and it's great and you need
to be optimistic and I think that's the
only thing that kind of keeps you sane
when it's so crappy around you when
you're just fighting battles all day
long it's that optimism that gets you
through it's that passion for what
you're doing that gets you through it's
the belief that something good is gonna
come from this when you're fighting in
the trenches that gets you through all
the garbage all the crap of working
because otherwise you would quit and go
do something else the thing that gets
you through is just a mad love for what
you're doing because then often at the
start it doesn't make logical practical
sense you continue doing it just because
you love it I look at this this career
that I've built for myself for what I'm
doing one of my very first speaking
engagements my first one in Canada was
at the YMCA and I went to this room and
they had this free event that we were
both promoting they had entrenar ship
program and I had you know some people
following me and I we promoted this free
event show up in his big room and three
people showed up
three people showed up to a free event
where there was already an audience and
so you could look at that experience and
say well if you could only get three
people to show up for a free thing how
are you ever gonna make it into a
business it doesn't make any sense and
when I first walked into the room and I
saw three people my heart sunk I felt
terrible I felt worthless I felt this
was a big waste of time like why do I
spend all this time preparing all these
slides in this presentation for so long
for three people and I quickly kind of
just suppressed that to say you know
what few people showed up I already did
the work let's at least give some value
to these three people and it was amazing
like it just it nourished my soul it
felt so good going through the content
and watching these three people come
alive and realize that they now had some
hope and they had they had a belief in
themselves that they would go home and
now hopefully bring this through their
business and see a big change in their
company in their life like that felt so
good that I could gift that to them and
walking into that room initially I'm
thinking this can never be a business
and I'm thinking just from a practical
point of view and I'm walking out of
that room at the end singing I have to
find a way to keep going even if this
never becomes a business even I never
make money off of this it was such a
good high just knowing that I helped
these people that even if I could never
find a way to make money off of this I
need to keep doing it because it fills
me it nourishes me and it's because of
that that I kept going through all the
garbage through all the crap well the
fights and battles and struggle to get
to where I'm at now the practice the
experience the grind is because it fills
me up and I eventually found a way to
make it make money I found a way to make
it become my career and this is going to
be the same thing for you
at the start you have a business plan
the business plan quickly falls apart as
you start actually getting into business
you realize this no matter how great a
plan you have what actually happens is
nowhere close to the business plan and
you need to adjust and every practical
logical sane safe reason in the world
will tell you to stop like this isn't
working you're putting time you're
putting money you're putting energy into
this thing and it's not working
but the absolute love for the craft and
what you're doing and how it makes you
feel keeps pushing you in that direction
to keep going and if you do that enough
you keep pushing through enough you keep
loving what you're doing enough you keep
getting better you'll find a way to add
value to the point where you're actually
helping customers and you can turn it
into a business most people don't have
the love to push through all the crap to
turn their dream into something amazing
so I'm challenging you to do it today
with yours
so the question day today is I'm curious
what's the hardest thing you've had to
push through in your business leave in
the comments below we're gonna join in
the discussion I also want to give a
quick shout out to Sean Terry Sean thank
you so much for picking up a copy of my
book your one word it really really
really means a lot to me and I hope
you're enjoying it thank you guys so
much for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is and I'll
see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of espresso
so hey believe nation thank you so much
for watching if you want to learn more
about this subject get a little bit
deeper on it I'm going to share some
extra bonus clips that I hope you'll
enjoy did you like that all the time and
then you push through it like you push
through it because what's the
alternative you're gonna leave that idea
stuck in your head forever that sucks
the alternative is you go through life
and you had this great idea and nothing
came of it because you got tired and
yeah sometimes you don't go to the party
that all your friends are at because the
idea is calling to you in that moment
wait for it's a great example of that I
was on my way to my friend's birthday
party when that lyric showed up when
death doesn't discriminate showed up in
my head
idea came on the a down I started
writing it down in the train and I can
eat that of the a train break dancers
are dancing I have my headphones on
I get out I the whole chorus comes all
at once I write it down and I suddenly
see the shape of the whole song I was
just like in the chorus is bur that's
who he is
I go into my friend's party I go hey
what's that man
happy birthday I gotta go I get on the L
train and I write the rest of the song
on the way back home from the L to the a
backup to 207 Street you have to do that
sometimes you have to say no to your
friends to say yes to your work because
what are you gonna do like lose that
idea because you decided like have a
drink with your friends like it's not
worth it your friend will be there
do you also went to Broadway with Julia
Roberts with Paul Rudd three days of
rain that must have been pretty special
yeah it was a do-or-die moment for me
actually I think kiss your confidential
had gotten cancelled you know I and and
I remember thinking if this doesn't work
maybe I'm not right for this business I
thought I thought that their mom
in life anything like you know it kind
of does matter if this fails or you fail
in it and and it was hard it was one of
the was the hardest thing I've ever been
through by far and I remember thinking
if I can get through this it'll it'll
maybe as hard but there's it's
impossible for it to be harder and it's
true and it's and I've had a lot of hard
time since and for jobs you know when
you're like wow the pressure is so
intense but it always I have such a
foundation for three days gonna say that
eight shows a week right
not even that actually was the rehearsal
process and I've to do once we got on
stage it flew and that thank God and I
thought oh this feels right but there
was a you know and I was hard on myself
you know but it was just man it was
tough see I'm a seed I really am I see
but a seed has to be planted a seed got
to have dirt put on top of it if you
take a seed and throw it on the concrete
and walk off the Sun just burn it up but
guess what
logically in my mind it doesn't make
sense that to grow something you should
dig a hole put it down in there and
cover it with dirt logically that don't
make no sense to me but odo see dirt is
necessary for growth and development
dirt builds character dealt dealt gives
you the push through factor dirt makes
you come with it when you don't feel
like coming with it no money and you get
dirt in a lot of different ways all the
other had dirt fold on you and dirt
ain't always what you want it's somebody
talking about you down on your job it's
somebody accusing you or something that
you didn't do if somebody telling you
you ain't gonna make it if somebody
shared information about you that ain't
true that everybody get dirt put on but
see when you getting put under that
stress please know God is always working
Kurt Franklin song God is always working
so I smile because I know he back there
see that dirt builds character in you
when they talking about you it teaches
you to withstand it
then it gives you something to push
through so when you put the seed and you
put the dirt on it if you understand
stress stress really ain't just dirt
stress see they don't call it dirt when
a planet they call it soil because the
soil has nutrients in it what the
nutrients when people talking about your
dog and you lie on you back by stealing
from you document you they're actually
putting nutrients now the see if they
put a camera under the ground you'd have
seen the seed sprout open and start
coming through the dirt because the dirt
is necessary so you can prove yourself
you know if you don't really want to be
everything you see above ground that
blossoms and plants and grows and that's
beautiful it was underground one time
all them potatoes collard greens they
was underground one time then apple
trees they was underground one time so
they had to prove they sell so you want
to be successful well then you got to
prove yourself you got to push through
the dirt you got to come up through here
you've got to come out then you sprout
again Bishop say then you become a treat
next thing you know you got fruit